[Music]
these three individual pigments can be
combined to create various shades of
brown this is Kelly dobos I've been
formulating products for over 20 years
I've worked for Bonnie Bell Jergens
lotion and Purell color Cosmetics is one
of my specialties and now she teaches
cosmetic science at the University of
Cincinnati So today we're going to break
down the ingredients in ilia's true skin
serum Foundation
aloe leaf juice there are over 35
ingredients listed on this 54 Foundation
Holly resinoliate but let's start with
pigments that's where those iron oxides
come in Ilia did not respond to the Wall
Street journal's request for comments on
any of its ingredients but Kelly says
those iron oxides are key here in
foundations we use four primary pigments
which are red iron oxide yellow iron
oxide black iron oxide as well as
titanium dioxide to tint the foundation
iron oxides are exactly like they sound
they're basically rust red iron oxide of
course is probably most familiar
titanium dioxide is used to tint the
foundation to different shades but it's
also added to increased opacity the
higher coverage of a foundation the
higher level of titanium dioxide see how
it turns into Brown when you mix them
all together all of these ingredients
are considered safe by the FDA however
titanium dioxide which is in many
foundations and sunscreens has recently
come under scrutiny titanium dioxide can
be a cost Cyanogen by inhalation
California's prop 65 requires businesses
to warn consumers about titanium dioxide
when it is in the form of Airborne
particles not in these liquid
foundations what we know about titanium
dioxide is that it is safe when used in
cosmetic formulations the concern really
comes from industrial exposures to
workers who might be in manufacturing
situations iron oxides have a moderate
safety score according to the
environmental working groups database on
personal care product ingredients
they're found in over 7 000 foundations
the iron oxides are a very smooth
feeling we don't want them to settle
where you would have to Shake Your
Foundation every time you want to use it
in order to prevent the oxides from
settling in the foundation chemists will
dissolve the pigments in a liquid that
has yield value something like this
ingredient yield value is the ability to
suspend a particle hand sanitizer
contains a polymer that provides yield
value you can see that it is suspended
in the solution another aspect of
Foundations is of course the main
solvent water is the best known solvent
to most of us it's a very low cost
ingredient the Ilia Foundation however
uses aloe leaf juice instead of water
which has to be harvested and processed
in order to use in cosmetic products so
that adds a significant cost to the
formulation aloe is about 98 water
making it a good substitute for
water
another underestimated ingredient I
think fillers often get a bad rep they
sound like they're not doing much in a
formulation but they're really important
to balancing the feel of a product
across the entire range of Shades
fillers help the pigments in the
foundation spread evenly Kelly says
other makeup brands have used talc as a
filler the talc used in cosmetics is
highly refined to remove any traces of
contaminants however there have been
some controversies where talc has been
contaminated with asbestos and that has
caused it to be removed from many
products the FDA says it continues to
test for contamination in cosmetics
containing talc Ilia does not use talc
its ingredients list rice whole powder
and boron nitride boron nitride and rice
powder are more expensive than talc and
they have additional properties like the
boron nitride provides the optical
blurring this Optical blurring from the
boron nitride helps create an overall
smoothness in the face so this line
represents the particle of boron nitride
we have in incoming lights
hitting the particle and it can be
reflected at the same angle or it can be
reflected at many different angles and
that's with the optical blurring effect
is
there are also skin care ingredients on
the list as cosmetic chemists we have
three different strategies for
moisturizing the skin those are using
humectants emollients or occlusives in a
formulation a humectant helps absorb
water like a sponge and an emollient are
an occlusive forms a protective layer
over the skin like this wax paper if we
look at the label for the Ilia
Foundation we have hydrating ingredients
we also have emollients glycerin is an
extremely effective at hydrating the
skin and it's also very cost effective
and it feels pretty sticky to the touch
as well the order of ingredients matters
cosmetic ingredients are listed in
descending order of predominance that
means the greatest concentration of
ingredients are closer to the top of the
list the Ilia Foundation contains
ingredients like niacinamide alantoin
and disavolol these are bringing
benefits to the foundation like skin
tone evening and additional hydration
the ingredients with skin care benefits
are are closer to the middle of the list
in this formula indicating to me that
there are at efficacious levels and much
like lotion foundations are typically
Emulsion products that means we're
combining oil and water or silicone
phases in the Ilia Foundation we have
polyglycerol2 isosterate as an
emulsifier hydrogenated lecithin can
also be used as an emulsifier and an
ordinary ingredient also helps you might
be wondering why sodium chloride
ordinary table salt is in this
Foundation well it's really doing a
pretty important job it helps stabilize
the particles in the Emulsion so that
they don't coalesce into larger droplets
and destabilize the formula but it also
helps lower the freezing point so that
the material is more stable when it's
transported once the foundation lands on
your shelf preservatives are responsible
for keeping the products safe from
bacteria different preservatives are
efficacious against different types of
organisms we have yeast and molds
bacteria so we often have to use
multiple to achieve Broad Spectrum
protection each time you dip your finger
into your product you're basically
adding bacteria to it and as cosmetic
chemists we do studies to simulate that
we call that a preservative challenge
test there are other things to note on
the overall packaging Ilia markets
itself as a clean Beauty brand clean
beauty is not defined in a regulatory
sense in the Cosmetics industry so many
retailers and brands have come up with
their own definitions of clean Beauty
and it tends to focus on more naturally
derived ingredients as well as
ingredients with known safety profiles
Cosmetics are not required to have FDA
approval before going to Market but the
FDA does provide guidance when it comes
to product Safety Safety First
I always bring up safety lab safety
especially when I see a picture
somewhere of a scientist and they're
like staring at a beaker and I'm also
like nobody stares at a beaker up in the
air you put it on the